all right fired up over continuing
locked down right now Arizona the latest
to experience protests these in Phoenix
right now where they look a lot closer
than six feet together don't think now
the protesters are saying enough is
enough people want to go back to work
they can what happens in these protests
as it happened in the applets happened
in Michigan happened in Virginia happen
in North Carolina that that sometimes
they miss their own mission here by by
doing the kind of things that prevent
danger or health hazards themselves and
that is congregating too close together
trace Gallagher has been following this
and so many other protests trace
yeah let's begin with Pennsylvania you
just saw Phoenix Pennsylvania had the
biggest protest kneel in the most
compelling pictures
this is Harrisburg Rochelle you the
capital where a few thousand ralliers
showed up to protest the shutdown
demanding the Governor Tom Wolf's reopen
the economy and again as you say very
little social distancing there and while
the protesters are making their case
outside both chambers of Pennsylvania's
GOP controlled legislature are planning
to come back in session in an effort to
limit governor Wolf's power to maintain
the shutdown but as all this comes the
governor is targeting May 8th as the
date for a limited reopening we're
talking about things like construction
retail shops online car sales let's go
back now to Arizona because there was
also some different types of rallies a
lot of people stayed inside their cars
calling for the governor to reopen the
economy they were practicing a little
bit of social distancing the protests
around the country were organized in
Phoenix and Pennsylvania on Facebook
like much of the other parts of the
country and here are a few opinions from
Phoenix watch this whole thing was a
mistake from the beginning to shut down
America we didn't know at the time it
was probably a good decision at the time
but now it's clear it was a mistake I
think there could be a staged opening
you know but we need to get make sure
that the health and welfare of Arizona
citizens isn't jeopardized first
yeah we should point out that Arizona
Governor Doug Ducey has targeted a May
first opening but he has given very few
details in that it's also worth pointing
out Alaska Montana and Colorado are
planning to open this week kind of
limited opening California has no target
date yet Neal and it's going to be 85
degrees here this weekend wondering how
the beach closures are gonna play across
the state interesting Neal to a lot of
these folks feel emboldened by the
President as says that's their ride you
know and deliberate you know one city
one state after another that he's
actually got their back they do I mean
you talk to these people and they
believe that you know this is their
right to be able to go out and say
enough is enough and a lot of this
really came Neal because people are
willing to play by the rules you talk to
protester after protester and they're
willing to play by the rules to a
certain extent but when they believe
there is overreach as in the case of
Michigan and the governor Gretchen
Whitmer there when they can't buy
gardening tools and plants and so forth
that's when the frustration level starts
to build and that's when you see these
kind of protests bubble up on Facebook
and they start to engender a great deal
of support so so we find that people are
willing to play by the rules and social
distance they know it's the right thing
to do but when they believe that
overreach is happening and governors are
not listening to their demands to reopen
the economy that's when you have this
bubble up across the country Neal all
right thank you Mike for a great
reporting as always trace Collier